we're gonna shine a spotlight on a
special person in our audience with some
good news to celebrate and she has no
idea that this is about to happen what i
love a surprise it's a surprise shout
[Music]
i'm looking for out special nurses in
our audience allison and eve allison you
nominated eve for a special shout out
today please tell us why um so i wanted
to congratulate eve on winning a daisy
award this year
can you explain what a daisy award is
because it's a very big deal so the
daisy award is a national nursing award
to um honor extraordinary nurses and eve
is just that she is um
lighting up the team
she is there for her co-workers for the
patients she always goes out of her way
to show her compassion generosity and
kindness to everyone around her
eve i'm so honored to work with you and
congratulate you um and recognize you
for this award oh come on
[Applause]
oh okay so yeah what's it like working
together
how long have you worked together
for about the past three years now but
over covid we've been working closer
together yeah yeah and you had no idea
this was going to happen i had no idea
and the daisy award is a very big deal
and you're an extraordinary nurse you
were honored um we're here to celebrate
you today and i would like to personally
bring you
for the daisy award winner
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you and thank you so
such much words you know
congratulations
it is so well deserved and thank you for
letting us join in in this extraordinary
honor that you've received allison it
was so beautiful what you said to eve
and eve you're so amazing thank you so
much for letting us be a fly on the wall
in this moment and you deserve all the
daisies in the world yes
[Music]
you